if we can't solve this loneliness
problem and redress the mental health
issues what is the future of this
country what we need is nothing less
than a major culture ship if we don't
consciously make rebuilding connection a
priority in our individual lives and in
society more broadly then we will
continue to see an erosion what you're
asking for is a revolution of
Consciousness the ask is not small
because the need is great
I think it's pretty safe to say that
there are a lot of people out there
suffering right now one out of every two
Americans is experiencing measurable
levels of loneliness one in two people
that's more people than suffer from
diabetes like this is a huge problem the
rates of loneliness are even higher
among young people the impact of this of
course is on our mental health but it
goes beyond that it's related to an
increase in risk for heart disease for
dementia for stroke and even for
premature death chronic loneliness can
lead to a Cascade of inflammatory
factors in our body and that can
increase our risk of illness the 21st
Surgeon General of the United States
vice admiral Dr Vivek Murthy is someone
I think it's fair to say has restored a
certain gravitas to his office that has
made him one of the most trusted voices
in America on matters of Public Health
in this conversation I'm proud to host
Dr Murthy explains how he arrived at
this church
and what we can all do to engender our
lives with more connection more
companionship and more community
it was an honor to host what I think is
a vitally important conversation with
such an esteemed individual so without
further ado
just me the Surgeon General of the
United States Dr Vivek
I'm extremely proud to introduce you to
our newest brand partner on check out
their lineup of super comfortable sleek
and durable pieces for yourself at
on.com
[Music]
well I'm delighted to meet you I'm
honored to be able to host you here
today thank you for coming well thank
you for having me on Ridge excited to
talk to you we had a poll here in the
studio as to whether you would show up
in your full regalia that you did I'm
very pleased to see you um
uh in your appointed dress and I guess
that that makes me curious around
the nature of of your charge your
mandate as as Surgeon General like what
is the Mandate and what is the the kind
of legacy of this being a naval position
like you're a vice admiral right so what
does that mean exactly like that seems
strange to the Casual Observer that it
would be a military position yeah so
it's interesting the the origin of our
service is it is an interesting story
behind it and it's the U.S Public Health
Service that I lead and it's one of the
eight Uniformed Services in the US
government so it's not Naval it's not
Naval um but the uniforms are very
similar to the Navy and the origins of
this service actually do have a a
maritime sort of connection which is
that when the Public Health Service was
in its original earliest stages uh it
was set up as a service that would
actually help protect the United States
from disease that ships would bring in
from the outside and so they would often
stop the ships and it would be
essentially a public health service
officer who would go out who would
investigate the ships uh see if things
were okay or if the ship had to be
quarantined and then in that way help
protect folks in the mainland from the
spread of disease so so sort of a public
health but also a national security
charge from the get-go that's right yeah
and over time the the service evolved uh
in in different ways but that mission of
protecting the public health of the
country has always remained at the
center so today we have 6 000 officers
who are nurses doctors physical
therapists pharmacists their Health Care
Professionals across the board and in
their day jobs they help serve in public
health roles in various regions all
across the country rural and urban areas
every state but more broadly during
emergencies we deploy them to respond so
for example when they're hurricanes or
tornadoes we send Public Health Service
officers to help Shore up the Health
Care System there to provide emergency
care to help support the public health
apparatus we deploy thousands of
officers during covid during the Ebola
outbreak in West Africa back in 2014 we
also sent hundreds of officers to
Liberia to help us set up a medical unit
called the Monrovia a medical unit to
help care for those who are sick so our
officers do an extraordinary job and I'm
incredibly proud of them proud to be a
part of the service but it's for that
reason that the Surgeon General wears a
uniform and we follow the rank system
that the Navy has so that's why instead
of
um you know I'm an admiral instead of a
general for those reasons right I got it
it's interesting and in terms of your
the scope of your personal mandate what
is your charge how do you describe what
it is that you do
yeah so the Surgeon General has two
primary responsibilities one is to
make sure that the public knows about
critical Public Health threats and
understands what steps they can take to
protect themselves and their families
and that traditionally has been around
issues like Tobacco For example but has
also included infectious disease
outbreaks HIV and it's included chronic
illnesses like obesity the other job of
the search in general is to oversee the
U.S Public Health Service Commission
Corps and that involves managing this
uniformed service of 6000 plus officers
you know for me I would say I actually
never thought I would work in government
I was never an aspiration of mine but
what happened to me is back in 2013 when
I was approached by President Obama's
team about serving in this role number
one I was and was surprised that they
had asked me because again it was not
necessarily looking to serve but what
was what did draw me to the role was the
fact that this is one of the few rules
in government that is a truly into
dependent position where your job is not
to execute the agenda of a president or
a party or any other group it is to
build an agenda based on what you
believe are the public health needs of
the country and so your Fidelity is to
science in the public interest first and
foremost and I really like that about
the role
um and so it's been an incredible honor
certainly to serve in the role now on
two separate occasions but uh the best
part has been really being able to just
visit parts of the country work on
public health with communities directly
and just hear from people about what's
on their minds and I'll tell you that
even though I came into the job during
my first term with a sense of what I
wanted to work on that agenda was
significantly shifted based on these
conversations I had with people I
encountered all across America who
really helped me understand what the
problems the deeper problems or the
deeper root causes of what's aaling us
yeah and that's what I want to get into
it is interesting that you have that
level of Independence you basically get
to wake up and decide what you think is
important based upon what you're seeing
hearing studying reading Etc and then
you get to deploy resources towards uh
solving whatever that problem is and I
have seen that Evolution and change and
you've arrived at a very interesting
place where there's a lot of clarity
around what it is that you're trying to
accomplish and the problems you're
trying to address and part of your
mandate is or the Mandate of of the
office is to
occasionally in your discretion issue
these advisories right and I think
probably the most sort of historically
resonant one would would be like Surgeon
General Coop with his secondhand smoke
what was that 1986 or something like
that yeah we all remember you know how
smoking was his big thing right
um and it's not often that the Surgeon
General issues these advisories correct
that's right yeah these advisories are
the historical office is historically
produced a lot number of reports uh you
know on Tobacco on HIV other subjects
but these advisories are targeted
documents that are issued on a shorter
turnaround basis when there's an issue
of urgent importance to call the
country's attention to and to call the
country to action to address and there
are a few of those that I have issued
during my time because we you know we've
been dealing with some urgent crises
they couldn't wait you know and so
during our time we've issued advisories
on the youth Mental Health crisis under
loneliness crisis on social media and
its impact on youth mental health based
on common questions I was getting from
parents so yeah these have been areas
that we've chosen to focus on in
addition to some more Niche areas like
Health worker burnout which also is
presenting now an imminent threat to our
emergency and Primary Care in the
country and when you issue these
advisories what is the the sort of
mandate of those in terms of like what
are they capable of achieving you're not
writing legislation right there are
policy initiatives they are
recommendations so where's the you know
what it what what are the the teeth in
this and and what are the kind of you
know weaknesses in these advisories in
terms of what they're capable of
achieving it's a really good question
and and you're right to point these are
not legislative or regulatory documents
they don't compel or require action what
they do is a few things one is they will
call the country's attention to a
particular issue and help lay out why
that needs to be a public health
priority the second thing they'll do is
they'll lay out concrete actions that
individual stakeholders can take these
might be
schools workplaces government itself
individuals families so we'll lay that
out often with a national strategy for
how we can address that particular issue
and then we take that advisory
two various audiences will actually work
with legislators you know on the issue
whether that's in helping them craft uh
legislation or advising them on
legislation they're trying to put
together or working directly with
Community organizations to do this as
well to implement their part of the
strategy one reason that these are
important Rich which goes beyond
um sort of traditional levers of power
that we think about like funding
legislation regulation is it's some of
the important changes we have to make
are actually cultural shifts and you can
mandate those or you know you can't
legislate those but but these are issues
that only happen if you call people's
attention to a national layout what kind
of shift has to take place and that for
example in particular is what we did on
the issue of loneliness and isolation
was layout not just the problem not just
a policy programmatic Solutions but laid
out what kind of culture shift we need
to create together as individuals and
communities to truly create a more
connected country so that's the power of
the of the advisories I will say if you
look historically back let's say in 1964
when Sergeant General Luther Terry first
issued the the very first uh you know
product on Tobacco from the surgeon
general's office that similarly did not
have it wasn't a piece of legislation
regulation but what it did do is call
the country's attention to this problem
lay out some solutions and mobilize the
country such that back then we had a 42
percent smoking rate in the country and
now we're looking at a level that's
closer to 11 or 12 percent and that's
because the community really responded
but it took a lot of longitudinal effort
and that's we're going to need on these
topics as well right to to identify a
problem draw awareness to it to announce
that this is indeed something that we
should be expending our our resources
and attention on uh on dealing with it
is you know the first step and you know
the acknowledgment aspect of it
it is yeah and one of the things I came
to appreciate during my time in
government also is that if you put
policies in place without building
adequate public understanding and
support for them
those policies are very tenuous they can
get turned around you know a few years
later they can lose funding support you
know when people choose to switch their
attention to a different topic it's only
when an issue has long Stan like a deep
understanding and and and I would say
buy-in from the public uh that we're
able to actually create the sustainable
programs and investment that we need to
truly address an issue and that's one of
the places where our office can uh make
a difference where we try to focus on
making a difference is in creating that
broader support awareness but also in
mobilizing communities to really take
action recognizing some of these
problems can't be solved by government
alone in fact I would argue that nearly
all of them require uh effort and
Leadership from communities as well well
certainly loneliness and isolation is
not going to be solved by government
alone that's right that's right um so
let's let's talk about that uh advisory
first this is an advisory that that came
out in May of this past year
um
I want to talk a little bit about the
origin story behind that in in your book
together and in your New York Times
op-ed piece about this you demonstrate a
pretty rare level of vulnerability in
recounting your own experience with
loneliness and isolation as context for
why this is an important issue so talk a
little bit about about that and the
decision to share that aspect of your
your personal life in into all of this
which is something we don't typically
see with uh with you know people of your
sort of stature and position well well
first thanks for those kind words Rich
you know I'll tell you that the more I I
have worked not just in public health
but in medicine more directly
the more of care for patients over the
years the more I've just come to realize
these issues are just deeply personal uh
for so many of us we can intellectualize
them in the form of reports you know and
write cerebral news stories about them
but at the end of the day like issues
like loneliness I think are very
personal we all have our own experiences
with loneliness we all know people uh
likely in Our Lives who are struggling
with loneliness and isolation
and I wanted to start there with the
personal because
that's truly how I come to this issue I
think about my own personal experiences
I think by the people I know and care
about who've been affected by loneliness
and that's a big motivator for me in
addressing this
um but I also think that there's it's
important for us to be able to be honest
with each other about what we've been
through if we want to pull down this
terrible curtain of shame that I think
still surrounds the issue of loneliness
and then more broadly still surrounds
mental health
um and so I I felt like the only way I
could ask other people to do that to be
open and to share their own stories is
why I was willing to do the same and in
my case when it came to loneliness I had
men had many deep experiences with
loneliness starting when I was a child
you know from thinking about those early
days in elementary school when I was
incredibly shy introverted had a hard
time making friends and I didn't really
want to go to school many days I
um that would make up the fact that I
had a stomachache on some days just to
stay home I really hope my mother
doesn't listen to this podcast because
she was the one I had to convince and
Sullivan told her that some of those
were fake
um but the reason I didn't want to go to
school is because I just didn't want to
feel like alone again I didn't want to
walk into the cafeteria yet another time
and be scared that there would be nobody
uh who would want to sit next to me I
didn't want to be the person who was
last picked you know to to be on a team
at recess not because I wasn't athletic
in fact I was I was very athletic but
because I didn't really know the other
kids well or have connections with them
um and so like from a child uh you know
that period of my life I experienced
loneliness I never talked about it
because I felt a sense of Shame about it
but then I kept seeing it in my own life
and the life of the patients I took care
of eventually when I became a doctor
like when I was in med school nobody
talked about loneliness in the curricula
it wasn't there wasn't a class on it but
I would say it was one of the most
common things I saw in the hospital and
as a young doctor I didn't know what to
do when I was encountering patients who
said
I'm all alone here and I'm really scared
about my Illness but I have nobody to
talk to I have no family I can call
there are no friends who are coming by
or yeah it's time for me to go home I'm
having a hard time walking I want to go
home but there's no one who can help me
there like there were these stories of
being isolated being lonely we just
abounded in the hospital and
I felt ill-equipped you know to deal
with it other than by lending an
empathetic year at the time
um but it was really when I became
Surgeon General and started traveling
the country and talking to people when I
asked them how can I be helpful that's
when I started hearing these stories
that went beyond my personal experiences
that really spoke to this Deep Well of
Loneliness and I'll tell you that people
didn't use that word very often they
never came up to me and said you know hi
I'm rich I'm the vague I'm I'm lonely
but they described a life where they
felt invisible where they felt like they
didn't matter anymore they didn't feel
seen
and I was hearing that from a lot of
young people as well which really
concerned me like kids who were on
college campuses surrounded by thousands
of other kids but yet still felt
profoundly alone so all of these
personal stories really went into
informing
how and why I decided to focus on this
and lastly the the story I shared in the
op-ed uh that I had written when our
advisory came out
um that was a particularly fresh one for
me because it happened after my my term
as as Surgeon General my my first
pharmaceutical ended uh ended up
abruptly and I was I found myself
without a team that I had come to
consider as family and I had also
neglected many of my pre-existing
friendships and uh and that had left me
also feeling quite alone and so I had to
contend with that loneliness I had to
contend with the sense of Shame and
failure that came with recognizing that
I just didn't do a good job at staying
in touch with the people I loved and the
people who loved me and I had to deal
with the the scary question that often
arises which is do they still want to
hear from me if I reached out with this
I'll answer my call
um do they still love me anymore so
those are the things I always found
myself grappling with hey big shot now
that you're not you know office anymore
now you call me right and and at a time
when they were in need perhaps and I
wasn't you were unavailable I was not
available like you know I still think
back on that I and I feel terrible you
know and and these more unconscious
decisions where I was like ah you don't
matter to me I'm crossing up a
friendship it was remember that no it's
like common I think it's a very common
thing I mean it's very common what you
experienced as a child I think that's
highly relatable to anybody who's
listening or watching uh but also
somebody who who is ambitious and and
has a demanding career it's very common
for that person myself included to lose
touch with friends when your time is
very limited and it's your job and then
it's your family and there isn't a lot
of room for anything else until you get
a couple decades down the line and you
realize like you miss your friends you
haven't talked to them in a long time
yeah but I found that those friends are
often doing the same thing and they're
always welcoming when you make that
effort to reach out I'm sure you
experience that as well
yeah I know that's well put and and
you're right because what what I was
reminded of by uh by somebody who an old
friend I reconnected with during that
time who I confided in and told her hey
I'm really struggling here
and she said you know your problem is
not that you don't have friends
your problem is you're not experiencing
friendship she said the friends are
there they may be latent they may not
have talked to them but pick up the
phone and call them
and you'll be surprised that they still
want to be there for you
and it was one of those times that made
me realize that one of the great myths
that we tell ourselves which is that
we will catch up with people later when
we have more time because that later
never comes and sometimes when we're
less busy they may be more busy and
it just sort of made me realize two
things one is that like later is really
it has to be now like in terms of us
making people a priority in our lives
but the second is that seeing in touch
with people doesn't have to involve
massive amounts of time either sometimes
it's the the brief Outreach that we make
to a friend on the way to work the five
minutes we may call someone to say hey
I'm thinking about you where it's
sometimes simply picking up the phone
when someone calls even if it says say
hey I'm about to start this podcast with
Rich then can I call you back later
um at 10 seconds of just hearing
someone's voice can make such a
difference and it feels quite different
from just texting them back yeah to say
hey I'll call you later so
you know because I think we're hardwired
to connect as human beings even a little
bit of authentic connection can go a
really long way to helping us feel like
we belong and that we are deeply
connected to other people
loneliness isn't something that's new uh
but what is new is this epidemic of
loneliness that that currently defines
our culture the statistics as you lay
them out are are quite shocking I think
you say one out of every two Americans
is experiencing measurable levels of
loneliness one in two people
uh
that's more people than suffer from
diabetes like this is
a huge problem right so I guess the
question I have is how did we get here
what are the tectonic plates that have
led us to this
state that we're in yeah it's the
numbers are quite shocking and you're
right that this is extraordinarily
common and as as surprising as the one
in two number is
the rates of loneliness are even higher
among young people which surprises
people who think hey aren't they
connected by technology yet they are
saying whether it's in spite of that or
in some cases because of the use of
social media the sense of connection
people feel has actually diminished so
how do we get here well several things
happen and we didn't get here overnight
either but I think that our sense of
disconnection has been building for some
time so here are a few things that start
to happen uh you know as over the last
20 30 years we have become more mobile
right so we move more often for work for
school
and we often move multiple times
sometimes in a short time frame whereas
before that people would often stay in
the areas that they grew up in they
would stay connected to the people they
were friends with in high school they
still lived around them but as you move
more communities become more fragmented
so that's sort of One Piece the second
thing that has happened is historically
going back Generations people tended to
live in extended family environments and
so you know not that that was all simple
or that was all good you know but but
those environments you know more often
than not unsure that people were
connected with others uh the shift away
from uh you know from extended families
has been one more factor I think it's
like people that live in smaller and
smaller circles
but the other factors I think that are
important here is that we've also seen
over the last half century a significant
decline in participation in the
community organizations that used to
bring people together particularly Faith
organizations but also service
organizations recreational leagues youth
leagues easiest to bring folks together
from different walks of life to get to
know one another to break bread together
to engage in activities together but
that opportunity has also been lost two
other factors worth mentioning one is
the rise of what I think of as
convenience technology right so today if
I I can sit in my home and get groceries
delivered to me I don't really need to
go to a post office I can get most
things I need from Amazon I don't need
to go to a store my need to go out and
have interaction with other people is
dramatically lower not just from a
practical standpoint so we have lost
actually a lot of those informal loose
ties if you will but finally I think we
have to look at the phenomenon of social
media itself which is dramatically
transformed how we interact with each
other and also has transformed how many
people see themselves and their
friendships and this is particularly
true for young people but while there
are some benefits of social media it can
be helpful to get messages out to share
useful information to share honest
reflections with a large group of people
far off more often than not what we're
finding is that for many people uh well
just like what young people tell me most
commonly tell me three things they say
their use of social media often makes
them feel worse about themselves as
they're constantly comparing themselves
others makes them feel worse about their
friendships as they're constantly seeing
what other people are doing without them
from feeling left out but third they say
that they can't get off it either
because these platforms are often
designed to maximize how much time we
spend on them not necessarily the
quality of time but the quantity of time
and what what is happening especially to
many young people but frankly to many
older people as well is that that is
taking time away from other critical
activities like sleep like in-person
interaction uh and other activities that
are essential for our health and
well-being so you put all these factors
together rich and what you see is that
we have become lonelier we become more
isolated and I think we realize and this
is not just an American phenomenon by
the way this is a broader feature of
modernity that the UK Australia Japan
and many other countries are
experiencing as well so we've got to
recognize that and it doesn't mean that
we should go back to 1920 or 1930 or
1950. but what it does mean is that we
have to recognize that if we don't
consciously make rebuilding connection a
priority in our individual lives and in
society more broadly if we don't do that
through individual actions in the
building of social infrastructure in our
communities
then we will continue to see an erosion
of our relationships and we'll see not
only the health consequences of
loneliness which are profound mental and
physical
but also the economic and the National
Security implications of loneliness
which make us more prone to division and
depolarization
every athlete I know is going to tell
you that having the right gear is key to
Performance if what you're wearing is
poorly crafted it's just going to put
distance between you and those goals
you've set you owe it to yourself to
invest in the best and the best is on
I'm obsessed with the cloud Ultra right
on the trails and I just got the new
next-gen Cloud Stratus 3 for the road
I'm loving those but on also has this
incredible line of lightweight high
performance apparel that it's just
beyond anything I've previously donned
it's like this second to none Second
Skin I love to rock the sweat wicking
Ultra tee and the ultra shorts which
have this pocket right at the base of
the spine that perfectly anchors your
phone no jiggle I'm just so proud to
partner with on and I love their vision
for the future where their gear is
fossil free and engineered for
circularity
so check out their amazing lineup of
super comfortable sleek and durable
pieces for yourself at on.com
that gets into the underappreciated
nature of this epidemic because it's one
thing to say okay A lot of people are
lonely yeah what does that actually mean
right we could talk about the mental
health implications of a lonely person
but there are also a plethora of
physical implications as a result of
loneliness that are not insignificant I
mean you say that lacking social
connection can increase the risk for
premature death as much as smoking up to
15 cigarettes a day and that
insufficient social connection is
associated with a 29 increased risk of
heart disease a 32 percent increased
risk of stroke increased rates of
dementia like there's a whole Litany of
Downstream Health complications that
result from this that I found quite
surprising
um
for the significance uh you know of that
impact
it is quite surprising I was shocked
honestly when I first came across this
data and
the more you look into it though it it
starts to make sense because one we
evolve to be connected to one another
for our Safety and Security
when we are under gatherers it was
people who were connected to one another
who shared their food supply who take
turns watching around the fire at night
those are the folks who survived who did
well versus the person who went off on
their own who said I'm independent I
don't need anyone else they often did
not survive but the other thing that's
interesting is because of that Evolution
and because our healthy relationships
came to be viewed as key to our survival
when we were disconnected from our group
that actually put us in a physiologic
stress State because we were worried
about our survival and it made sense we
had good reason to worry then
interestingly though even though our
circumstances are different now our
nervous systems are very similar to how
they were thousands of years ago so when
we feel separated from other people when
we feel lonely we find ourselves in a
physiologic stress State as well now
short-term stress is not necessarily
always a bad thing right so if I for
example feel stressed before giving I
don't know a big speech or before
turning into an assignment
um if used well that stress might
motivate me to focus more and and to
perform better
it's when stress is Extreme an amount or
prolonged in duration that it can become
particularly harmful and that's where
chronic loneliness which puts us in a
chronic stress State can lead to a
Cascade of inflammatory factors in our
body and that can increase our risk of
illness and that's frankly what we're
seeing in the data with increased risk
of cardiovascular disease and other
medical conditions one of the insipid
things about loneliness is when you are
lonely you are less inclined to seek
help like when I feel lonely I just
double down on isolation like I don't
want to connect with anyone right so
you're basically by by kind of leaning
into that feeling you're digging the
hole even deeper and deeper and deeper
so what is going on neurologically what
is the neurochemistry of loneliness yeah
that's interesting and I it's a question
about that I want to ask you actually
but I'll say that this is a common
experience that people have they chose
that even though they're lonely like
they don't want to reach out they
actually withdraw more and that's
I think it's for a couple reasons one is
when you're in a chronic stress state
that can be exhausting over time as well
it takes some degree of energy to reach
out to people so sometimes when you're
struggling with that for a while it just
saps you your energy you don't reach out
but there's something else behaviorally
that's happening which is that
loneliness takes a toll in your
self-esteem over time as well and you
come to believe as I did when I was a
child struggling with loneliness that
the reason you're lonely is that you're
not likable or you're not lovable
something is wrong with you and that
actually makes you less confident about
reaching out to other people makes you
not want to be rejected there's a third
element here as well which is that
loneliness puts us in a state of hyper
vigilance right so back to go back to
the the example of hunter-gatherer days
when we were alone separated from our
group
we entered a state of hyper vigilance
where we were particularly on the
lookout for any threat that might be
around us now you can imagine us for a
good reason like if there's a twig that
snapped behind us in those days even if
there's a one percent chance that it was
a predator you wanted to interpret it as
a threat because your life would have
depended on it but think about that in
the context of loneliness now when I'm
feeling lonely yes my energy has been
sad my self-esteem has been hit but also
in this state of hyper vigilance where
now you rich come over to me and say hey
um do you want to get lunch tomorrow
now the normal
you know expectation would be I would
say yes because I'm feeling lonely right
and a hyper Vigilant State though I
might look you would suspicion be like
is Rich just trying to like take pity on
me uh is he does he think that I'm a
loser and somehow I can't find friends
on my own like heck I'm not gonna like
do that I'm just gonna say no right so
and that seems this very nonsensical but
your things are fundamentally shifted
when you're struggling with loneliness
for a long period of time it changes
your perception that's where the hyper
vigilance is like you would think of it
almost like a a different set of glasses
with a different shade on it that's
changing how you're looking at the world
around you and you can if you and I
guarantee you all of us have encountered
people in this circumstance it may have
happened to us as well and sometimes you
encounter somebody like that at work or
in another social setting and you think
ah they're aloof it's people are
approaching them but they don't seem to
be responding they're pushing people off
but loneliness is the great masquerader
it can look like aloofness it can look
like withdrawal it can look like anger
and irritability which is often how it
presents uh in older men and so it's we
have to be thoughtful about that and
recognize that it may not seem like it
from the outside but a lot of people
around us based on the numbers we know
are in fact struggling with lungs yeah
there's a whole Cascade of of emotional
uh experiences as a result of that the
lowering of self-esteem the sense of
worthlessness so if somebody asks me do
you want to go to lunch I may not look
at them with suspicion but my sense of
self is is so disempowered and feeling
so worthless that I can't imagine that I
could go out in public I can't be seen
by anybody else or this person doesn't
really want to have lunch with me right
there they feel sorry for me yeah and so
no I'm going to say no to that yeah
that's right
um can I ask you rich a question you
mentioned that um sometimes when you
felt lonely you felt that
that sort of pull to withdraw more
rather than reach out what have you done
in those circumstances that's allowed
you to to actually end up reaching out
to folks or what's worked for you
um well I'm also long time in recovery
uh so I'm a 12-step person so I have a I
have a toolbox of tools and so I've
developed that reflex to pick up the
phone and call somebody when I feel like
that even though that's the last thing
that I want to do
um and that's not to say that I'm always
great at that but I know that I have
these tools available to me and I have
communities of people that I Rely Upon
who give me feedback keep me in check
know how I'm doing know when I don't
show up and the like and I realize that
that's not everybody's circumstance like
that is a peer group
um that's super important to me in
addition to my family and I have another
men's group that I go to and I have
friends and the like but I also can get
very caught up in this and this can be
all consuming meaning like what I do for
a living and I can make you know I I can
make my life very small as a result of
that and it's not until uh you know many
weeks of that before I come out of a fog
and realize like I haven't called a
friend or I haven't gone to a meeting or
I haven't done these other things that I
know that I need to do to maintain my
mental health and and my physical health
as as well so
it's imperfect I would say
um but those are the general kind of
tools that I have available
I do it all I'm curious about the men's
group you mentioned that you're part of
a men's group how did that come to be
uh friends in the area
um I have one friend he said hey I'm
getting some guys together and we're
gonna have a therapist who's gonna
moderate we're gonna do this once a week
do you want to do it I said yes he said
okay and we we had our first meeting and
the rule is if you're in town you come
there can be exceptions here and there
but this has to be a priority and it's
something I've been doing I think maybe
five years at this point that's great um
once a week uh which has been great uh
and supplementary to to 12 step because
that's a different thing that's very
specific about a very specific problem
um whereas the men's group is more like
how's your relationships like do you
want to run a business idea you know
it's just like other like-minded guys
who are going through life in various
stages where we can kind of share our
experience is solicit feedback uh
received the feedback which I think is
really important
um and hold ourselves accountable I
think everybody should try to create
that in their community
and they're friends you know but also I
need to have friendships outside of you
know anything structured also
yeah did you find when you first joined
the men's group was it
they come naturally to you to to be a
very open in the group or did that build
over time
it was natural because I had years and
years and years of 12-step in therapy
under my belt so I I don't have a
problem being open and vulnerable in in
that context but I had a lot of practice
so I realized that's a leap for a lot of
people vulnerability is frightening and
I think again you know the way that we
open this conversation me crediting you
for being open and vulnerable about your
own experiences you can't expect other
people to follow your lead and to engage
in that unless you're willing to do it
yourself and so I'm always trying to
model that on this podcast because
there's a great strength in that I think
you know we think that it's weak or
we're afraid to show people who we
really are but
weakness is keeping it to yourself yeah
it takes courage to share those things
and and every time that I have and I've
seen other people do it
um not only are does that set them on a
trajectory towards uh greater
self-actualization and healing
um it's empowering and it's received
welcomingly by those who are on the
receiving end of it um so powerful I'm
so glad you had that experience in the
12-step program of
sharing openly and being vulnerable
um it sounds like that may have been a
process through which you that you had
to work through to come to that point
where you felt so open
um
but I mean something I've long admired
in the recovery movement is the
recognition that in addition to
potential medical therapy and counseling
the community is really essential oh 100
like you know I think about all the
thousands of people I've met over the
years in this job and as a doctor
directly with patients like how many
people I've met who are in recovery and
I'm having a hard time thinking of any
of them who have made it into recovery
without somebody or the community at
their side or somebody who helped them
through that difficult process so
I think it's absolutely essential I
think your experience also in this
conversation I think highlights the fact
that we need those kind of communities
everywhere in our life right not only
for uh you know for recovery but
for dealing with a lot of other
challenges that we encounter whether
they're relationship challenges whether
they're health challenges
um one of the broader movements that I I
really love in medicine has been the
move toward uh doing group visits with
patients and trying to build communities
of patients that can support one another
through difficult health challenges
um so yeah I think this should it feels
like they should be a key pillar of how
we live Our Lives having these kind of
communities yeah and modernization has
driven us in opposite directions from
that in in every regard
um I was in Europe the other week and
had the Good Fortune of visiting a few
different cities and realizing that the
infrastructure of a lot of
cities overseas are orchestrated to
cultivate and create Collision in
community in ways that our cities and
suburbs are certainly not right and
that's that's a big part of the problem
as well
it really is yeah and
I even think about in in workplaces for
example and think about how we design
workplaces how we design schools
um as well as how we design cities we
want to make
connection easier both with the people
you know and care about and want to see
but also with other community members
and strangers you may not know and one
of the things that was interesting to me
during the pandemic was how which was a
time I think when among many other
things people were so separated from one
another
is I had many people came to me and said
you know I expected to miss my family
and my friends that I did not expect was
to miss seeing strangers in the coffee
shop or other people in the grocery
store
but all of those touches all of those
connections
they really do matter and I had some
experience you know in traveling through
Europe some time ago also recognizing
that wow these places feel like they're
built to make collisions and connection
happen but that is part of what uh what
I mean when I talk about social
infrastructure you know the social
infrastructure really the programs and
policies and structures in a community
that support the development of healthy
relationships of people coming together
and I do worry as you said that we are
moved away from that we've cut our
cities up with with highways we made it
harder for people to to run into one
another and again with the benefits of
Technology we've gained tremendous
efficiencies with having things come to
us where we are at home groceries uh you
know retail items
but we have lost something as well which
are these collisions with other people
who are part of our community
so in terms of the solution you have
this six pillar plan part of it is top
down what is government's responsibility
what is the private sector's
responsibility what is the legislative
regulatory landscape look like to try to
address and solve this problem and then
you have bottom-up Solutions like
protocols that every individual can can
practice to improve their uh their sort
of connection hygiene Community hygiene
so maybe talk a little bit I mean you've
already kind of canvassed it but
specifically what are some of the
top-down solutions that you would like
to see moving forward
so you know with the caveat is both of
us have said that you know this is not a
problem for government alone to solve uh
but government does have a role here in
building Greater connections so some of
the top-down things that government and
private sector can do is
um number one the government has the
ability to to identify an issue as a
national priority and to bring the
community together to address it
critical stakeholders that's a real
government Kennen should play government
can also invest in research so we can
better understand not just who's most
deeply affected but what strategies work
uh to address loneliness and
disconnection
um that's a critical role and then
government can also look at its own
policies
we're used to looking at policies with a
financial ends to see how much does this
cost and how much revenue might it bring
in I think we should also be looking at
policy with a connection lens to
understand how is this actually going to
help or hurt the ability of people to
come together and build healthy
relationships if we had thought about
that with housing and transportation
policy over the last century I think
that some of our decisions perhaps would
have been different so government can do
that in terms of the private sector
workplaces actually can be intentional
about how they design not just so
physical workplace for workplace culture
to create opportunities for people to
come together and get to know one
another there are things we do in our
office for example not that we are
perfect we're still working in progress
but the things we do to try to enable
people that come to know one another for
example we when I was Surgeon General uh
the first time we had this practice we
called our inside scoop exercise where
we would have uh one person during our
All Hands meetings once a week we'd give
them five minutes at the top of the
meeting to share pictures with us and
give you pictures of anything they
wanted but just as it was it wasn't
about their current job and people bring
in all kinds of things pictures about of
their family pictures of activities and
sports that participated when they were
younger when they had those dreams of
being uh you know a figure skater or you
know professional athlete
um
and they would bring in pictures of uh
you know of us other things that were
revelatory about their lives that helped
us understand who they were that five
minutes often helped us understand
somebody more deeply than the year that
we often had beforehand just bumping
into them so there's workplace design
issues and in schools as well I think
that we cannot take for granted anymore
that people just automatically have the
skills confidence and wherewithal to
just build healthy relationships from
the get-go what we're seeing and hearing
directly from young people today what
I've heard from University chaplains
including earlier today you know
chaplains who are looking out for the
mental health and spiritual health and
well-being of students on campuses is
that they more and more young people are
telling them that they don't feel
comfortable actually going out and
starting a conversation with a stranger
or asking someone out on a date or
dealing with conflict you know in a
relationship or disagreement so they'd
rather remain silent my whole life is on
text
yeah and there's not even by talking to
people on the phone it's all texting on
the phone yeah and we lose so much
Nuance right the Nuance that we evolved
over thousands of years to be able to
interpret everything from body language
to tone of voice to uh everything that's
unsaid that's all part of how we
communicate but we lose a lot of that uh
when we're at a distance just through
text so these kind of skills though I
think if it needs a social emotional
skills or relationship building skills
are what educational institutions can
also play a role in providing so these
are a lot of the government and private
institutional uh solutions that we need
uh coupled with the the idea that
Community organizations YMCAs Boys and
Girls Clubs and and Faith organizations
can also play A Renewed role in helping
to bring people together across
differences uh to learn about one
another to to form stronger connections
so those are a lot of the top-down
Solutions as you might think of them and
these have to be combined with the
bottom-up solutions the individual
actions that we take in our lives
because one thing I don't want is for
people to look at the profound challenge
of social connection of social isolation
and loneliness and just saying gosh this
is just too big to solve like with
somebody with a lot of power and a lot
of money he's got to solve this but us
Everyday People we can't do anything
about it and that's actually not true
because I think a big part of this is
change in culture and changing
individual practice and culture shifted
when our beliefs shift when we choose to
act differently and here if we decide
that we're going to make a shift from
the lives that we live now which are
often work center lives to truly living
people-centered lives then we can start
doing that just by keeping five minutes
every day when we're reaching out to
someone that we care about just to say
hey I'm thinking about you want to know
how you are we can do that by making
sure when we're interacting with our
friends and with our family that we're
giving them the benefit of our full
attention and putting our devices away
which is easy to say so much harder to
do and I say that as somebody who has
been distracted often during
conversation is working on that too we
can also do that by looking for small
ways to serve other people to help one
another service is not just going to a
soup kitchen and volunteering it's
helping someone when you see them in
need whether that's a helpful word
whether that's literally helping them
with papers that they uh that they they
dropped or with a cup of coffee that
they spilled these small acts of service
they tell someone else hey you matter I
see you you're not invisible and that's
a message that people need to hear so
there's a lot we can do in the face of
the loneliness crisis and the other
piece of good news is that
these small actions they can feel good
even if we haven't solved the entire big
problem yet right and and when we start
to take those steps we just realize the
truth I think that biology and research
have told us again and again which is a
we are hardwired to connect with one
another when we give ourselves the
opportunity to do so in an honest open
authentic way even a little bit of
interaction like that can make us feel
really good for a long time yeah let's
beautifully put when I think about
avenues for connection that exists
particularly for for young people you
think about youth leagues Park leagues
after school sports after after school
programs places for people to go YMCAs
and even the faith-based uh
organizations they're all
uh in decline or have evaporated so I'm
interested in in what's causing this
certainly there seems to be a a bit of a
maybe at the very root of spiritual
malaise but
um also a funding uh you know malaise or
or a lack of political will or you know
I don't know what it is but those
Avenues don't seem to be as robust as as
they once were and and that seems to be
you know a huge
kind of contributing factor to all of
this yeah no you're you're spot on and I
think the reason I think different
reasons why these different institutions
have decline in participation I think
when it comes to
Faith organizations
I think that there has been
especially among younger Generations uh
a disinclination to participate or
affiliate with faith organizations now
the reasons are varied some people say
it's because they've lost faith uh well
no pun intended but they've lost trust
uh in faith institutions and they they
look at you know transgressions they
look at uh scandals they look at all
these things and they ask themselves who
can we really trust
um I I worry that that means they also
lose a lot of the community and benefit
that comes with faith communities but I
think that's a factor uh when I was
talking to
um uh some University chaplains earlier
today in fact an interesting statistic
they told me is that at their
universities they said that greater than
50 percent of the students say that they
have no religious affiliation
but 75 of the students say that they are
spiritual
and that's important spirituality is
important to them
and what they say and this is echoed by
so many other uh chaplains that I've
spoken to as well is that the spiritual
hunger is still there
among younger Generations
they just have not felt an Avenue for
them to explore that in a community
context that's right that's right the
traditional institutions have not
they're not feeling connected to
um I think also when you look at other
types of organizations service
organizations or recreational leagues I
think part of what may be happening
there that I worry about is I think we
have put so much pressure on young
people to lead
the perfect life to achieve success you
know with quotes around it here but
where we define success as a fairly
narrow set of things achieving a fancy
job you know a certain level of income a
certain level of public recognition or
perhaps perhaps fame
um and in the context of that you might
look at things like hey just
volunteering at an organization your
community as
inefficient or a distraction because how
is it contributing to your success in
that traditional definition
um and similarly like look this is I I
think an interesting thing that kids
need is in addition to every child
needing
loving relationships in their life and I
mean that of all things that's perhaps
obviously one of the most important
things uh you know recipes for success
for a child is to have loving
relationships in their life but kids
also need unstructured play time
they need the opportunity to explore and
be creative they need the opportunity to
work out things on the playground and in
other settings with other kids that's
where they learn social skills how to
negotiate how to communicate how to deal
with conflict
and when we don't give kids that when we
hyper structure things for them when we
make sure that they're not only going to
school but they're doing six after
school activities here and there that
are all hyper-structured I worry that we
are depriving them of that open space
and creativity that they need uh in
their lives
um so look for I think a bunch of
reasons participation has gone down but
I think one of the biggest things is in
plain sight which is that I just don't
think we thought that these were or
recognized how important these were you
know I think similarly with I think they
decline in relationships and increase in
loneliness over the last several decades
has not been because we made an
affirmative decision that relationships
don't matter it was more a consequence
of neglect right where we said hey all
this other stuff has become really
important we got to chase this
and when you realize that relationships
don't just happen Community doesn't just
get built it's an investment that has to
be made a priority that has to be
safeguarded further confusing that is is
social media which was built on the
promise of increasing connection right
which in fact it's working at Cross
purposes with in in many ways and that's
the subject of of your other advisory
you mentioned
um National Security uh and that's super
interesting I think
you know when I think about the impact
of loneliness on National Security
um I can't help but think about
the
it's sort of a third rail issue the
extremely online
disenfranchised young male who doesn't
have adequate access to an upwardly
mobile trajectory for himself finds
himself you know in the proverbial you
know basement of his mother's house
engaging with people online uh who are
activating their their
um sense of disenfranchisement by
provoking their anger and their
frustration and and channeling it in a
certain direction and we've all seen uh
the violence that can erupt from this um
so when you're talking about
National Security I would have to
imagine that it includes trying to
figure out how to uh help this cohort of
of young people
um that I think are suffering right now
and and creating kind of real world
havoc and this is an important point and
I think most people don't recognize it
loneliness is so much more than a health
issue like when we are
divided and isolated it is easier for a
foreign adversary for example to come in
and to spike the information environment
with misinformation or disinformation in
that case right to create confusion to
turn us against one another
um
versus when we're more connected with
one another
we tend to give each other the benefit
of the doubt right we tend to even if we
disagree on issues still be there to
have each other's backs think about that
relative who you might get together with
at Thanksgiving or over other holidays
who may have different political views
from or views on other issues but at the
end of the day you know if he or she
ended up in the hospital you'd show up
and vice versa because you have a deeper
well of trust relationship you give them
the benefit of the doubt when you don't
have that you can be exploited as a
society and I think to your point about
young people who are feeling alienated
and disenfranchised I do worry about
that a great deal because for some
people they'll re react to alienation
and to loneliness by just withdrawing
further and further but Others May May
Express that as anger and when uh when
people are led to believe that they
should blame specific groups or certain
people for their loneliness and
alienation then it can lead to harm to
those groups and to violence which is
not productive for anyone and is
destructive for society so I think part
of this has to involved on the one hand
recognizing How Deeply people are
affected by this how painful in fact
loneliness and alienation are but it
also has to involved giving people
healthy Pathways to build community to
address that look at the heart of this
Rich we all as human beings have three
core needs we all want to know that we
are seen and understood we all want to
know that we matter and we all want to
be loved
and if we don't have those
then we don't do well we can't survive
in the long term
and so the question is how do we help
people feel seen and understood how do
we help young people know that they
matter well I'll tell you one way we
don't do that is by telling them that
the only way they matter if there is if
they're successful in the traditional
way if they earn a certain amount of
money if they uh you know have a certain
amount of Fame have a certain amount of
power
um and the people who remind me this of
this every day that are fundamental
worth is not extrinsic but that it's
intrinsic are my kids right I think
about my kids are five and seven when
they were babies I remember how they
didn't need to be taught to be
in the moment they need to be taught to
be loving and expressive that's just who
they were still remember talking to
um
the son of Daniel Barton who is a
six-year-old child who was killed in
Newtown uh during the horrible school
shooting that took place in 2012. and
Mark Daniel's father told me that even
as a six-year-old Daniel had this
instinct to go up to other kids who were
alone on the playground
or alone in the cafeteria
then just to go and sit next to them
sometimes he'd ask them how they were
doing sometimes he would just be present
and sit with them knowing that no one
should have to be alone
that instinct is I think what so many
children are born with
and we just lose that over time because
we get told that that's being naive
that if you're too nice of people
they'll hurt you we have difficult
traumatic experiences in our lives that
may lead us to shut off from other
people
but part of what we have to recognize is
that what we need is nothing less
than a major culture shift
to recognize that we have to move from
living in a world where we are stoking
fear and shift back to a world
where love is powering what we do in the
form of kindness and generosity and
service to one another we have to decide
that one of our core values is going to
be that we have each other's backs that
we don't leave each other alone and
leave each other behind and that shift
starts with each of us with the
decisions we make in our own life but
how we treat other people how we
interact with our community
if it's built on by the decision we make
about
who we advocate for
I'm I have kids but my neighbor may not
have kids but they may go to a school
board meeting
and advocate for better funding for our
schools because they know I have
children and I matter to them right like
advocating for people who may have
interests that are different from ours
but because we know them we believe they
matter that's got to be a part of how we
build a society that's more centered on
love as well and this is also about the
decisions we make in
in our schools in our workplaces think
about the leaders that we choose one
thing I've learned about leadership over
the years is that 90 plus of the
decisions that leaders make they make
behind closed doors when the cameras
aren't there
and what's guiding them in those moments
are their values
at some point we came to think that the
values of our leaders don't matter that
it's just their policy positions that
matter
but that couldn't be further from the
truth I think this moment in particular
is one where values matter so if we as
individual citizens have the power to
shift culture and to choose a core set
of values centered around kindness and
generosity and service and friendship
centered fundamentally around love and
we can do that by the choices we make at
you know in our homes in our communities
at The Ballot Box because that's how we
change society sure uh very ambitious uh
but but beautiful in its
heart-centeredness and as you were
sharing that I'm thinking about
the actual implementation of that and I
and it it's it's really what you're
saying on some level maybe you disagree
but what you're asking for is a
revolution of Consciousness because
we're in a culture that that where the
where the incentives are misaligned
right like we're rewarded for being
snarky and ironic and cynical and owning
the other side and we're looking up to
the wrong role models and we're being
told that happiness is found in luxury
and convenience and wealth Etc uh when
in truth everything that ails you and
that which you most seek can be found in
service kindness generosity
um being a friend uh seeking out
friendship holding yourself accountable
to somebody else and modeling a certain
way of being in the world that you would
like to see percolate out into the
collective Consciousness and it does
start with who our leaders are and how
they're modeling their values in public
irrespective of the decisions that
they're making behind closed doors when
they get up behind a Podium and the
cameras are on them how are they
acquitting themselves publicly what are
they saying not necessarily even in just
their words but in their demeanor in
their behavior and what they choose to
focus on and what they choose to respond
to and how they respond to those things
that stuff matters and it percolates
down into our Collective awareness of
how we're meant to be in the world so
what you're asking is no small ask but
that is the question right and short of
us being able to
for lack of a better phrase grow up and
and and you know mature
um what is the future of this country
right if we can't solve this loneliness
problem and redress the mental health
issues and the downstream kind of domino
effect of that I don't see that we have
much chance of cohering as a as a nation
yeah we can't communicate
we don't share the same set of facts
we're not interested in our fellow man
because we've been told that our Liberty
and our freedom and our individualism is
what's most important so in so many ways
we have it backwards and and you're
asking us to
truly remember who we are
to really understand what is important
and to begin practicing it that's right
and that was beautifully put and and
you're right that the ask is not small
because the need is great
and in moments of great need when we're
faced with that I believe is an
existential crisis and a crisis of
identity because this is an identity
crisis we're trying to figure out who
are we like what is important to us
and I believe that our identity should
be defined by these core set of values
if you live life
without a moral compass
it's hard to know where to go
and we may we have more and more choice
now than perhaps we've ever had before
but what good is all that choice if you
don't have a compass to guide you
and so this is what we need is nothing
short uh of oh as I think of it a moral
renewal in our country where we
re-center on those core values we
determine what our identity really is
and a core part of that has to be
recommitting to one another it has to be
a commitment to these values that we're
talking about around kindness and
generosity around service and friendship
and we've got to do that not just for
now but because our kids future depends
on it you know my I think any parent out
there knows that while your kids
sometimes listen to what you say they
more often listen to what you do
and our kids watch what we do they why
we might say hey be kind to someone else
but then if we are vitriolic and abusive
to other people whether it's in person
or online
that inconsistency does not serve our
children well so you know I I believe
that fundamentally we have to get this
right
the other pieces getting the right
policies in place building the right
programs making the right financial
investments as a country these stem
from that deeper culture that moral
identity that we have as as a people we
have to get that right because if we
don't uh it's like we're revving up our
car but we're going in the wrong
direction right and you also but you
also can't make it a sense of obligation
or make people feel like Martyrs in
doing this right you have to create a
culture that's conducive to these
choices being the preferable one and
people doing it because they're
realizing that it makes them happier not
because it's necessarily the right thing
to do out of obligation but because this
is the better path that makes us happier
it's better for our kids is better for
society you know all the way down the
line that I'm really glad you said that
actually because
I think what's interesting about this is
if we start building on this movement
for a moral Reawakening in America I
actually think it will make people feel
better in the doing of it and I think
that will make it easier for them to do
and to continue to build that movement
and here's why like think about the
example of
an experience you may have had in the
past where let's say you were engaged uh
in a service project in your community
uh and maybe one person joined and they
made it a little easier for other people
to join like ah so-and-so my friend I
guess maybe I'll volunteer and do that
or think about somebody in the office
let's say who maybe had a time of need
maybe a relative passed away or they got
really sick and they needed somebody and
somebody stepped up to say hey you know
what I'm going to go over and visit them
and then other people join and said you
know what I'm going to do the same too
one person stepping up made it easier
for others to do the same and it
actually feels good to do these things
it actually feels good to serve other
people not only do we help them but we
feel useful ourselves feels good to be
kind to someone else to see the benefit
that it that accrues to another human
being from our own actions and it feels
good to be courageous and bold which is
I think of course skill and trait that
we want to cultivate in young people as
well these things feel good when we do
them but there's an activation energy
it's infectious it's infectious right in
a really good way
um which is why I I think about this
advice that an old Mentor of mine gave
to me at a time where I had an idea that
I wanted to build and I wasn't sure if
anyone I thought it was gonna be too
hard to do and I was scared nobody would
care about it and wouldn't support it
and what she said to me is she said
Vivek when you stand in strength
you allow others to find you
and I think about that often because
every time somebody stands up and lives
out one of these core values we're
talking about every time they're kind to
someone in distress every time they help
somebody who's in need every time they
give someone the benefit of the doubt
instead of judging them or blaming them
they're standing in strength and people
watch us our kids watch us our neighbors
and family members watch us and it
reminds them
of a better way to be it's not that we
are saying we are better than them we
all have the good and the bad inside of
us we have the ability to be incredibly
loving and we have an incredible the
ability to hurt other people as well
it's what part of ourselves we choose
that can not only make us feel better
but can serve as an inspiration for
people around us yeah that's that that's
beautiful I I call that the lighthouse
effect you stand in your power you're
not necessarily trying to change
anyone's mind or to even Advocate your
position you are just in your strength
solid sturdy and that becomes a tractor
beam for other people yeah when you
model it that way how is how has
um this exploration in into loneliness
um and into social media I guess as well
uh impacted your parenting style I mean
your kids are still young so the devices
I'm sure are not in their hands yet but
well this is an interesting yeah what's
going on yeah so it has actually
impacted
so I'd say one on the loneliness front
we have um we've made it a real priority
over the last few years to make sure we
are investing not necessarily in objects
that we can buy them
but in experiences with people that we
can create for them
and for us that involves making sure
we're
using you know whatever vacation time we
have or other breaks to get them to see
their grandparents to see their aunts to
be with family and friends it means even
though sometimes we're tired on a given
day trying to make some simple you know
create some simple opportunities for
their friends to come over so they have
some time with them or to have some
unstructured play time
um with other kids in the community so
we're trying to create those experiences
for our kids because one we know the
connection is important but also I'll
just saying on a personal level you know
having struggled with being really shy
and introverted and lonely when I was a
kid I I look at my on my son who's seven
right now and I I see some similar
tendencies in him
um I look at my daughter who's has a lot
more fire you know than I had when I was
a child and in a really good way and but
I see how shy she is and and I do find
myself worrying about them so you know
kids evolve at different Paces but I
want to make sure that we're doing
everything we can to create the
environment and opportunities for them
to really connect with others lastly you
know on the technology front I'll tell
you honestly this is hard you know like
they are these devices are so intuitive
for kids right that even I remember when
they were you know two years old uh if
they saw us using their phone their eyes
just immediately went to the phone and
they grabbed it and they wanted to use
it
um and you know we would take the phone
back but we can tell that they're
magnetically drawn to these devices and
they can't figure them out very quickly
and so one of the things they're too
young to use in social media but that
doesn't mean they're not aware of it my
daughter when she was in preschool came
home one day and asked my wife and I if
we could post a picture uh on a social
media platform for her
I'll be like what how do we even know
about this platform how do you like know
that pictures should go like we were
flabbergasted but her preschool
classmates
were talking about posting pictures on
social media so we know we have to be
vigilant there and part of this for us
is about protecting time though without
devices so we for every we have a
curated list a sort of set of videos
that we uh will allow them to watch in
small doses from time to time when we're
on an airplane for example over here and
there
um things that have some some sort of
educational or cultural value to them
things that don't have harmful content
in them
um so we try to limit how much time they
spend there but we also know as they get
older that we made the decision that we
want to delay their use of social media
until they're well past in middle school
and potentially beyond that that's not
easy to do it's incredibly hard but one
thing we know is that it'll be easier if
we can do it with other parents and this
is something that I've now heard more
and more from parents of kids who have
older kids is that this is really tough
to do on their own but when they find
one parent two parents who are willing
to make the same decision for their
child whether that's delaying the use of
social media or whether that's drawing
Tech creating Tech free zones their
child's life like not using social media
or technology in the half hour before
they go to bed and throughout the night
or around meal times it becomes a lot
easier when you're doing this with other
parents it's still not not simple
because over the years I think a lot
largely this technology has spread like
wildfire without any real guard rails uh
you know to limit children's use and and
to healthy use and so what you're seeing
is that it's become this expectation uh
that every child is on it in some cases
schools are even assigning homework that
requires a use of devices and some cases
of some social media platforms so we
have to to pull back a bit and get to a
place where we can have Tech free zones
where parents can work together and
support one another in delaying use
um and I I think when we're planning to
do that until one we feel that our child
is actually developmentally ready to use
social media and two until real
safeguards have been put in place and I
mean specifically safety standards like
what we did for automobiles that we are
now calling for in our advisories to be
applied to social media and until
there's data it actually tells us that
these platforms are in fact sufficiently
safe for our kids like we don't let our
kids take medicines that aren't study to
be safe and effective we don't put them
in car seats that haven't been certified
to be safe
yet we're having them use these
platforms which are profoundly changing
how they see themselves and others with
scanned data to reassure us at all about
safety
yeah it's uh it's a huge problem I'll be
interested to see how that progresses
for you as they age it's almost like an
asthmatotic curve like with every year
uh you know the pressure
um to get the device to be online in
that way increases exponentially
um and it's a hard problem because on
some level fluency on those platforms is
a gateway or kind of um a key to having
a social life right if you you can't be
a lot I you would be a social Pariah
amongst your peers and your classmates
as a young person
um who's on the outside it's sort of
like the kid who doesn't kick get picked
for the Kickball team is the kid who's
not part of the Snapchat group chat or
whatever it is right so that complicates
it from a parenting point of view which
can understand that the two interesting
things that I've learned recently one is
that as I've talked to more and more
students like a middle school and high
school students who are actually
building movements to actually get off
social media and get on offline they
often have they in the beginning when
their parents told them hey you can't
use this until later they fought it and
they were angry
but over time they actually came to feel
a lot better because they saw themselves
less subject to a lot of the anxieties
and struggles that their peers were
going through as they you know engage
with bullying harassment online or
constant comparison with other people
but the other thing is as that community
grows and builds those kids aren't alone
right and there are more parents I also
encounter who are looking for what we
use the term dumb phones right phones
that don't have the capability of having
social media but have the ability to
text uh to look up to make phone calls
to use maps so good for safety good for
communication with friends
but don't necessarily subject you to all
of the other potential adverse effects
of social media so I think there are
additional Pathways that we have to
build here but you're absolutely right
that it's not simple and in there's a
transition challenge here which is why I
think it's so important that we do this
together with the support of other
parents I know my wife and I can't do
this alone if we left up to us alone we
probably fail at some point maybe cave
in at some point not be able to deal
with the pressure uh you know and you
know worrying about our kids being left
out but if we can find two three four
other parents who might be similarly
inclined then not only is it good for us
but we know our kids won't be alone
either yeah yeah yeah that's interesting
I mean I have found that there's a
certain level of sophisticated
astuteness in young people like 20
somethings they're on an accelerated
sort of learning curve with all of this
yeah um that that I missed or whatever
and and they're way more analog than I
am and they do have those dumb phones
and and uh and and they have learned and
I think the pandemic probably
accelerated this to appreciate in-person
connection yeah
um early right and and I think that's
reframing that generation's relationship
with technology in a really interesting
way and it'll be interesting to see what
the generation coming up your kids age
you know how they're going to experience
this because everything is happening so
quickly yeah 10 years from now it's
going to look completely different and
hopefully it will look more like the
world that you're trying to craft
I hope so and what you're saying
actually
it reminded me of the conference where
we started this conversation with
12-step groups right because and there's
an interesting connection here which is
one third of of adolescents who are
using social media right now say they
feel addicted to social media half of
them say if they had to get off of it it
would be incredibly hard for them uh to
do so
and when I talk with Educators I would
think it would be even higher yeah well
this is what people are willing to say
on surveys so I think chances are it is
higher
when I talk to Educators interestingly
what they say is that when they have
made decisions to for example not allow
phones during lunch breaks or in some
cases in during their class for example
they find that kids Grumble but a lot of
times they thank them afterwards and
they say you know we felt a lot better
you know just being able to not
constantly be on our phones but the
question is if you felt better why
didn't you do it by yourself
because it's not easy to do by yourself
right because separating yourself from
that device is hard when they've been
designed specifically to maximize the
amount of time you spend on them to suck
you in and and you're being asked to
separate yourself from the pack you're
exactly you're asked to do something you
have to apply to everyone yeah and we
also I think for adolescents in
particular we just have to recognize
that they're not just younger adults
they're fundamentally at a different
stage of brain development where they
end Social Development where they are
more prone than adults to social
comparison and to social influence and
so you put all of this together and you
recognize it what these a lot of
students are telling Educators is true
which is that they may see the challenge
but in some cases they need a little
help and support in creating the
environment where they and the
opportunity for them to actually
separate and when they do and experience
that a lot of times they want to build
on it just like the 20 year olds that
you're talking about uh and that's the
same thing that's I think that's part of
the reason why we're seeing more
communities of kids coming together to
say hold on we're we're tired of this we
want a different path it's not to say
we're estewing technology and putting it
at the side we want to use technology
responsibility responsibly but we don't
want it to rule Our Lives we want to be
the people who decide how it's used and
we want to have a life that's lived
outside of Technology because the truth
is
everything that's happening in social
media is not necessarily real life right
there's real life happening offline and
sometimes to truly connect with others
we have to disconnect from technology
and I think that's what many of these
kids are doing and the life that's
happening online is not an accurate
reflection of what's happening in the
analog world all you have to do is
scroll Twitter for a while you'll get a
very thwarted you know view of what's
actually happening versus what it's
actually like to live your life
uh you quoted this this study this
longitudinal cohort study of U.S
adolescence that said kids between the
age of 12 and 15
um
that adjusted for Baseline mental health
status found that adolescents who spent
more than three hours per day on social
media face double the risk of
experiencing poor mental health outcomes
including symptoms of depression and
anxiety but we know that there's a lot
of kids who are even younger than that
and basically every kid is on social
media more than three hours a day
yeah so the average is three and a half
hours a day right now which is obviously
higher than that number of three hours
and
even though technically 13 is the age at
which many platforms say people can
start using them
about 40 percent of kids 8 through 12.
are using social media so those rules
are not being enforced adequately either
so you're right I think the concern is
great here uh that and this is one of
the reasons I issued this advisory is it
was in response to a question that
parents kept asking me which is are so
is social media safe for my kids
and putting all this together I think my
two most important takeaways were number
one we don't have enough evidence to say
it's in fact safe and two there's in
fact growing evidence that it's harming
many of our children and that statistic
is is one of those data points
and I think this is just for me a
cautionary tale also of how
we have to be thoughtful about how we
Embrace and integrate new technology
into our lives it's not that we should
push away technology look I'm a Believer
in technology I use technology I spent
seven years building a technology
company I I'm a Believer technology but
it's ultimate in how it's designed and
how we use it that ultimately impacts
how it affects our lives and I think
particularly when it comes to our kids
I think the I I think you you can judge
a society by how well it cares for and
supports and protects its children I
think under many ways we've done a great
job in society on many other fronts uh
making sure our kids have vaccines
available to them making sure that
public school is something uh you know
that that's a it's it's a reality in our
country for for children but
I think here we we drop the ball and I
think we've got to catch up and do
better because you know it's it's not
okay to just say well the horse has
already out of the barn so whatever is
going to happen is going to happen we
can't control it that's an unacceptable
uh a response to the the current
situation it would be like if we went
back uh to a time when you and I were
younger when more motor vehicle
accidents were really high and just said
well you know cars new technology
they're improving our lives this is just
the cost of new technology people are
going to die instead what we said is
we're not going to go back to horses and
Buggies but we've got to make these
safer and we worked hard to put safety
standards in place that got us crash
testing air bags seat belts and a number
of other safety measures that over time
reduced motor vehicle fatalities and
we've got to take that same
determination rigor when it comes to
making social media safer for our kids
like with loneliness it's a
top-down set of solutions and a
bottom-up set of Solutions in The
Advisory there's there's recommendations
for
government involvement what is the
responsibility of big Tech what is the
responsibility of the parent what is the
responsibility of the user right there
is no one culprit here everybody's gonna
have to buy in on some level and
participate in this and I would say that
even
the Behemoth big tech companies
understand that this is a problem and if
they're interested in in continuing and
perpetuating and innovating that they've
got to find a way to uh cooperate on
this I think they under they get that
right like I just had the episode that
went up on the show
um today is with Francis Haugen who blew
the whistle on everything and and maybe
that prompted Facebook to be a little
more receptive to uh you know what needs
to happen here but what is your sense of
receptivity with the technology
companies and and what is the political
will
um
in terms of legislative and Regulatory
change
well these are the right questions and I
think that
look I
I giving the you know the benefit of the
doubt here I you know I suspect that
most of these platforms began with
people who thought they could create
more Connection in community you know by
building social media platforms
um but at the end of the day I think
you have to judge your technology by the
effects it has on people and you have to
measure those effects and you have to be
transparent about what that data shows
and we haven't necessarily seen that I
think Francis is
a testimony her bringing voice to some
of that data that was internal I think
confirmed for many parents what they had
suspected which is that there are
negative effects on our children that
we're not being told about and many
researchers in fact have told me a
researcher spent years working in this
area social media's impact on Mental
Health have said that they have not been
able to get all the data they need from
the technology platforms to be able to
do a full assessment and understand the
full impact of social media and the
mental health of kids look as a parent
rich
I don't want to ever feel like
information is being hidden from me
about
the things my kids are using like if you
told me that can you imagine the Uproar
if it was determined that a car seat
manufacturer was hiding safety data from
parents they would understandably be
just incredible anger and frustration
and so we got to apply the similar
principle here so I think while
companies I think recognize increasingly
that there is a problem here in terms of
the mental health impact of their
platforms
what I don't think is going to happen is
that we're going to get to a place where
these platforms are safe solely by
relying on the companies to fix the
problem we didn't rely on motor vehicle
manufacturers to fix all the safety
issues entirely on their own we didn't
say you know good luck we'll hope and
pray that you do a good job here in the
20 years since social media emerged on
the scene we've not seen the kind of
change or data transparency that we need
to make these platforms safe for our
kids so what we need are is external
accountability and that's where having
Federal safety standards is essential
and why parents have to be at the table
when those standards are developed and
why it actually has to be enforced so
look I think technology companies
ideally should be willing Partners in
this it's one of the reasons we lay out
recommendations for technology companies
as well
but I just worry that we have right now
a business model that is based on time
spent instead of time well spent and you
know how companies resolve that you know
is is certainly a challenge that they've
got to figure out but you know as
Surgeon General is a doctor as a dad
most importantly my biggest concern is
making sure that whatever my kids are
exposed to and are used
has been sufficiently evaluated for its
safety and until that happens with
social media I wouldn't blame any parent
out there for being skeptical about
allowing their child to use it sure I
mean because of the misalignment of
incentives the big tech companies are
not going to willingly Implement these
sorts of safeguards because the business
model is orthogonal to that so it is
going to require intervention
governmental legislative regulatory
intervention my sense is that there is
bipartisan support for this serious and
that's a good news here rich as you know
I've I've spoken with members of
Congress and uh and for both parties and
uh you know spoken to the president
about this I've spoken to many folks in
government and across the board their
strong interest in in doing something
real and in fact just recently
um the kids online safety act was
finally you know pushed forward by the
Senate uh and this has been a bill that
had been worked on for uh quite a long
period of time and it's a one step
forward uh it's not the only step we
need there's is there's more that has to
happen but the point is this is a moment
in time
where parents are feeling the pain of
this and they're calling for Action when
increasingly young people are saying to
us directly and in surveys that they
recognize that social media is harming
them where there is bipartisan support
and we have to use this opportunity to
to move forward and finally take the
action that needs to be taken these kind
of Windows of opportunity uh to do the
right thing they don't remain open
forever you know there's always stuff
happening people can get distracted by
one issue or another but one of the
reasons I issue this advisory and I've
continued to focus on this issue is I
think this is too important for us to
get distracted from
um we can't because every year for a
child
is an extraordinarily important time in
development for them our kids childhood
is happening right now we can't say come
back in five years and we'll fix this
got to do that because every day
um you know I we're I'm getting stories
from parents who are telling me about
how their child was harmed how their
child was exposed to content that urged
them to take their own life or to harm
themselves how they were harassed
exposed to racist remarks to misogyny
online
um
you hear this again and again and again
from parents who are saying why is this
happening why isn't someone doing
something about it why doesn't someone
have my back we will put the entire
burden of managing this new rapidly
evolving technology on the shoulders of
parents who never grew up with it
it's not fair or on young people who
don't have the brain power or skills to
rebut its addictive lures that's right
and what that basically is is it's
pitting the best developers and program
designers in the world against parents
and kids yeah and you're bringing a
knife to a gunfight on that one that's
not a fair fight and and that's why
we've got to have the backs of kids and
parents on this issue and again I can't
think of something that's more important
for us to address look when it comes to
mental health more broadly we've with
kids you know I've at lent spoken about
the importance of us improving access to
treatment we got to do that we're
investing more in the last two years in
that that's a good step forward there's
more to do there
but if all we did was focus on treatment
and didn't address these deeper root
causes like loneliness and isolation
like social media which are impacting
the mental health of Youth
then we just can't keep up with the
demand you know like
universities are compared to 10 years
ago many of them have hired double
triple in some cases quadruple the
number of Mental Health Counselors and
they still can't keep up with demand so
we've got to get at the root causes of
some of this and this is why addressing
technology and loneliness are so
critical uh I do have one last question
for you it's a question
it's a tweak on a question historically
over the decade of doing this podcast
every time I have a medical doctor on
the show I kind of end the episode by
asking them if they found themselves
transported to a parallel universe and
woke up and realized that they were the
Surgeon General what is it that they
would you know what would be their their
mandate what would be the thing that
they would try to you know make happen
and I've had a lot of very interesting
responses to that most of them fairly
idealistic not that yours isn't yours
might be the most idealistic Mandate of
all of them but here I am in a very
surreal moment where I actually have the
Surgeon General sitting before me so I
can't ask him that question but I know
that uh there's a sense of urgency your
your term may be coming to an end we're
not sure maybe you're going to be around
for five more years who knows but
what is it that on a very practical
level you want to make sure it gets
accomplished uh before your tenure is
over what is the what is
beyond what we've talked about like what
is the real Legacy that you want to
leave behind you know the I always think
that the question of legacy is tricky
because that's for others in history to
determine but
you know the issues we've talked about
today are certainly close to my heart
the thing that I want most
for our country
for our children in particular the issue
that I'm increasingly talking about and
want to build an initiative around
is this broader
question of what is our vision for our
country what is our identity
as a nation
and to me this is inextricably linked
with the core values that
I believe should Define
how we live our lives and how we build
our communities we have a choice right
now between a world that is
mired in fear where people are angry at
each other where people are feeling left
out like they don't belong like they're
on their own
where they feel invisible
and a world where people feel like they
belong
where they have each other's backs
where they feel
that the future is something that we can
shape together regardless of what may
come because we don't have to face it
alone we can face it together
this that is a choice
that we have to make about which world
we want to live in and it's a question
of identity
and I think we have to decide
where we want to come from like as
individuals as families as a community
that we want to come from a place of
fear do we want to come from a place of
love
and if we if every anything I can do as
Surgeon General is a most importantly as
a concerned citizen to ensure that we
choose the path of love
that we recognize that love is our
greatest source of strength and it's our
greatest source of healing and they will
reflect that in tangible ways and how we
behave and how we treat each other and
the choices we make in our life and what
we demand from our leaders and how we
design our institutions
to me that is what will transform
Society for the better it's what will
allow us to put in place policies that
extend health care to everyone who needs
it that make sure that we're supporting
our schools and ensure that we are
working towards uh lifting up everyone
from an economic perspective these all
flow
from the core values that we commit to
and so that that to me is the most
important thing I want
to do over the next year is to help
build that broader moral Reawakening
that we need in our country to support
it in whatever way I can and to gather
the people
who are out there who I know believe
strongly in this who have faith that we
can be better
than what we've been over the last few
years that it's actually fundamentally
who we are that who we've been the last
few years that that's not the true our
true nature and I've seen this in our
unguarded moments when no one is looking
in the heights of the pandemic I saw
Neighbors who went over to help others
who were struggling I've seen after
tornadoes and hurricanes people come in
together disregarding their own safety
to help people who are struggling and
having a hard time I've seen nurses and
doctors who put themselves In Harm's Way
during coven
to take care of people that they had
sworn an oath to care for
selfish people don't do that
mean-spirited people don't do that
but that's not Who We Are
so we've got to make that choice and
right now it feels like the choice is
being made for us
that were steeped in this information
environment that's extraordinarily
negative that's telling us everything is
broken about the world that nobody can
be trusted and that everyone is only out
for themselves
we've got to turn that off and tune in
uh to what's actually happening in our
communities and choose again love I
always say that
every decision that we make
we can ask ourselves a question am I
making this decision I'm out of love or
out of fear
and if we choose love as often as we can
then we'll build a kind of life that
feels good for us that's good for our
communities
that our kids can be proud of that will
help create the world that ultimately
future Generations need I would say
that's a pretty good answer to the
question thank you for that
um beautifully put
people are good
if we raise our Consciousness we can
solve all of our problems and it stems
from operating from that higher place so
I really appreciate that was that was
really lovely
um we need more leaders like you
I appreciate the level of service and
integrity that you're bringing to your
office
um it's very commendable uh this life
that you're pursuing and I have so much
respect for what you're doing I was
listening to a podcast that you did with
Scott Galloway and he he had mentioned
that
um you bring a certain or you've
returned a certain gravitas to this
office and I think it's very true
um thank you I'm At Your Service uh it
was really beautiful to spend this time
with you so thank you for that so many
things I wanted to talk to you about
like tons of other issues I hope you'll
come back because I'd love to talk to
you about
Health Care versus sick care uh you know
addiction
um so many other things so yeah I really
well listen I'd love to do that would
love to continue the conversation and
happy to come back whenever
um and thank you for this conversation I
just I must say I was incredibly
impressed when I read your bio and
learned about your story and um
but I feel even more disappreciative of
who you are meeting you in person and
just feeling the the reflectiveness that
you have and the thoughtfulness with
which you pursue conversation but
your kindness also just comes across uh
very clearly and so
I'm grateful for this conversation we
had together and thank you for all the
the good that you're bringing into the
world through your podcast I appreciate
that that means a lot
um also check out your podcast house
calls we didn't talk about that either
we have lots of guests to overlap
um amazing that you're doing a podcast
uh given the the office that you hold I
think that's really cool
um and also I will put all the links to
I'll put I'll put links up to the PDFs
of the advisories in the show notes so
people can find that as well as links to
all of your information but if you
wanted to direct people who are
listening or watching to one particular
place where where do you want them to
turn well our central location a
repository for all our products is
searching general.gov and so there you
can find our priorities page which has
all of our core advisories on it so feel
free to go there
um and we try to write these advisories
so that they're easily digestible to the
public you don't need a PhD or a medical
degree to be able to read them and their
as well so please check them out all
right thanks so much man it's great
appreciate it peace